guys the audio for my special Lefty sun
is out I've released it as an album it
is available on audio everywhere iTunes
Spotify you name it it's out there go
check it out and support my special on
YouTube thank you I'm very excited to
announce that we have partnered with
Spotify it changes absolutely nothing
for you the added benefit though is that
you now get video on Spotify you're
going to get the Honeydew audio and
video on Spotify we're very excited to
partner with Spotify it changes
absolutely nothing for you you're not
having to pay for anything or anything
nothing's behind a pay wall none of that
you're just now able to get audio and
video on Spotify so go subscribe to the
Honeydew on Spotify today the Honeydew
with ran
[Music]
sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pan
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan sickler
dcom Ryan sickler on all your social
media and I want to say thank you thank
you to everybody that supports this show
however you support this show if you're
listening if you're watching uh whether
you're new here or whether you've been
here or whether you go back to the feast
thank you for you supporting me I love
my job and I probably just got
demonetized for saying that right there
but I love my job and I love it cuz you
guys and look if you have to have more
I'm telling you you have to check out
the patreon it's called the Honeydew
with y'all and it's this version with
y'all and y'all have the wildest stories
anyone's ever heard they don't stop
hitting us they don't stop coming it's
five bucks a month that's it there's no
tears none of that stuff five bucks you
get the entire Library not just a month
everything thing hundreds of episodes
for five bucks a month all right and if
you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to go listen to my old podcast to
crab Feast that library that podcast has
been dead almost five six years and it's
going to do over a million downloads
feaster nation is still strong it's an
audio podcast from back in the day and
it's got everyone you love in podcasting
soora ker bitki Bill Burr everybody
they're all there with different stories
so go check it out and come see me on
tour if I'm in your town when you're
around come out check me out the live
and Al live tour I'll be in La Hoya
California October 20th through the 22nd
I'll be in Salt Lake City the 27th and
28th of October bavia Illinois November
10th and 11th and then closing out the
year December 8th and 9th in San
Francisco California that's it that's
the biz you guys know what we're doing
over here I always say we highlight the
low lights and I always say these are
the stories behind the story tellers and
I'm very excited to have this guest on
today ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Jason Muse welcome to the
Honeydew yay thank you you clapped
yourself in bro yeah you you look good
in lavender too man you do you're a dad
you're looking good bro I look I told
you I met you outside I saw you huge fan
stoked that you're doing this uh but
before we get into your story please
plug promote everything and anything you
would like um so we Kevin Smith and are
doing h a uh a cruise which I'm I'm EXC
I've never done a cruise before I've
never been on a cruise that is me either
um and I've been a little little I never
gone because I've been a little worried
about getting out there but but I think
it'll be fun uh it's it's going to be
February 23rd uh to the 26th I want to
make sure I don't mess this up uh of
next year uh and it will be from Miami
uh to Nassau Bahamas so February 23rd to
26 um and there we're going to do our
podcast the one we we don't do it
anymore but Kevin and I used to do Jay
and S Bob get old we're going to have
podcast Hollywood Babylon fat man beyond
Ed vacation there's going to be uh
standup comedy
tournaments um there's G to be live
music Solo's going to be there Sol you
know clerk soundtrack so there's GNA be
live music uh some some uh poker
tournaments with everyone on board uh
stand up com I'm excited I think it'll
be fun because I don't drink uh and I'm
sober and stuff and I don't I can't
imagine going on a cruise where
everyone's partying and doing stuff I'm
not saying there people won't be
drinking a little bit but I feel like
there's GNA be so many things going on
I'll be able to keep busy and do fun
things and are you worried about that
have you been in an environment like
that since I mean you're in a [__]
crack house on the water basically yeah
yeah no you know what I'm saying like
that's a drug
B well the good news is though I feel
like you know my main drug is is either
you know let's say crack and heroin
opiates um and I feel like people don't
really share that it's not like they're
on the boat smoking crack you know
exactly it's mainly weed yeah exactly
never again I remember I remember I used
to be dope sick and I'm like I wish
someone would share with me but I mean
constantly people like you want to smoke
some weed you want to drink but again
and I like those but I I don't crave
them and I don't like it's not hard to
be like you know I can't get there
because if I start that then I'm going
to get to the other you now let me ask
you this cuz if you're an addict I'm
just curious how that crosses cuz we're
going to get into this yeah but um
gambling you said was going to be on the
boat do you do you do you have cuz I'm
not an addict when it comes to gambling
I don't go onl but when I go to Vegas my
ego is like we can win we can do it I'm
like no we can't but I'll [__] I'll
I'll go way more than I should if I'm
there I've been good if I'm there I've
been you know I have this thing where
it's like don't get me wrong there's
been a few times where I feel like I'll
keep buying in and or if I'm playing
Blackjack I'll buy but I feel like 300's
using my limit and I think that I've
gotten the most I've lost is maybe a
thousand and then I like hit it I was
like that's it I can't lose more so and
I and it bugs me enough that I can stop
like again so I'm not worried about that
and I don't you know and on the boat
we're going to be doing more of a
tournament I think we're going to be
doing like prizes and stuff so I feel
like tournaments are definitely more fun
you can buy in a couple times um I'm
also we're going to be try I'm trying to
get see if it's possible and get
together um a gaming tournament so I've
been TW the one other thing I want to
plug is my twitch
twitch.tv juse so I've been streaming on
Twitch for three years I play games I
unbox things um and it's live and anyway
twitch.tv juse but I'm hoping to like
try to get a gaming tournament on the
boat a bunch of people from my stream I
don't have a whole lot but I have a
couple hundred people each time I sign
on that watch live and stuff and a bunch
of them were coming on the cruise so I'm
hoping to get that together um but I
don't know it'll be fun so but yeah the
cruise is February 23rd 26 and you could
it'll be fun so come I I think it'll be
great Jason Lee will be there Ethan SLE
Dante brandle which is Brian oh' Haller
and Jeff Anderson from clerks um and
Clerks 2 and clerks 3 whatever um but
yeah I it's going to be a blast hell
yeah so it'll be fun well let's talk
about your life a little and how you got
here clean and sober and everything cuz
it starts in Jersey I know you're a
jersey guy you're are you 50 now too 49
49 you're about to be 50 you have an
eight-year-old girl yep and you I I
don't know why I thought it was a
seven-year-old but you just said you
have a seven-month-old we were talking
yeah so so you're about to be 50 and you
have a a kid that's under one a baby
yeah a baby you know a baby yeah it's
tough and again it's like and it's funny
cuz I almost I feel like you know it'll
be easy easier you know everyone says
it'll be easier but I feel like there
was such a gap and I got so into the you
know it's like after the baby years and
like follow him around making sure
they're not putting stuff in their mouth
and all the crazy scary things I'm not
saying there any things I worry about
with my 8-year-old as you know but I
feel like there was a routine it's like
I wake up get her ready for school she
eats breakfast brush her teeth drop her
off at school I know I have and then she
has activities usually after so like I
drop her off at like almost 9:00 in the
morning and I know that I have till like
3 or 4 to do whatever it is but now it's
like now I got to rush home hey B do you
need help she like yeah I need to do
this this and this so you're going to
watch the baby now and you know I'm
going to take up for a walk sometimes
he's fussy he's teething and it's uh
yeah it's been interesting and and uh
I'm a little little worn out some days
it's funny because I it's like the
double EDG short I'm I also do sorry
musing stories which is my standup uh so
I've been touring uh with my standup
comedy I just came back from Portland uh
at The Helium Comedy Club but like I
hate leaving the kids cuz I miss them
but then at the same time like I swear I
slept 12 hours each day man it's like
goes with me that's what tell her I go
on the road people like you like I'm
like I just go get sleep yes I just
sleep I know and I feel bad I I don't
really no offense I don't I mean your
city's cool but I don't really give a
[__] about your Museum right now I'm you
got to eat this food you got to eat this
and then I feel bad cuz there's always
like people that I'm friends with from
other town so they came to my show and
I'm excited they're there and I say hi
to them for 10 15 minutes they're like
hey you want to go do something I'm like
look I'm not being rude I really want to
spend time with you and hang out but I
got to go to sleep man I'm going to bed
yeah especially because I've noticed to
like I'll wake up and go out and do a
couple things maybe get some lunch and
then if I don't come home and nap for
some reason like right before the show I
feel like all a sudden 6:00 p.m. if my
shows at 7:30 I'm like I'm so tired I so
now I've learned and like even if I go
do stuff I'm going back to nap I'm going
to go lay down at 1 nap till 4: or
5 and it's like taking nap
since so it's it's uh yeah it's
interesting [__] speaking to my heart
that's me you get in late I sleep I'm
like God it's 12 I take my time getting
up go out get a little bite to eat try
to take a nap or at least hit the gym if
I can and then yes try to get the Zone
yeah it's a lot it's yeah it's not the
same as back in the day when I'm like
yeah I'll meet you here and we'll stay
out till 2: and then oh you want to go
to this place and you know it's so can I
ask you a personal question you do not
have to answer this is is your new baby
was it intentional or were you just was
it an accident okay so you both this
yeah thank goodness both of them were
well not thank goodness but I feel like
we were just a little more prepared both
of them were planned uh when I hit 40
almost it was almost my 40th birthday or
what have you um my wife was uh is 13
years younger than me um and she wasn't
ready up till right around my 40th
birthday I'm like listen I'm 40 now like
if we're going to have a kid can we have
a kid and stuff and she was like oh and
then she's like all right I'm ready
thank goodness uh we were like all right
let's start trying I'm ovulating two
months into a three months we were
pregnant um and that was our first one
and then you know seven years or
whatever it is later she's like I'm
hitting 35 which I didn't know until we
started trying with the doing like yeah
she's like I'm I'm going to be geriatric
to have a baby I'm like wait what do you
mean you're 35 like I learn this too
here I'm like that's an ice cold 35 to
call it geriatric pregnancy yeah cuz I
we had one and I don't remember them
saying maybe I just don't remember it
but I don't remember them using that
term I feel like we were um not an
elderly or Advanced or something like
that I feel like this I would have been
like geriatric cuz my my daughter's
mother was 41 when she was born 39 when
she got pregnant I was 41 yeah and yeah
we're well over into a geriatric
pregnancy and and and it's not 35 was
the number and I was like that's so
interesting and but yeah she knew and
she's like I think if we're going to do
it we should do it now and I was like
are you sure like I won't be getting 49
and stuff um and she was like yeah like
I really want one and stuff I was like
all right let's do it and you know this
one was a little bit longer like she
even got worried at one point was like 5
months in 6 months we still weren't
there yet and then uh you know we
started doing some funny little things
she read on the internet like I hold her
by her ankles upside down trying to
shake change from her Pockets uh trying
to let gravity take fact and stuff but
yeah after about six months so yeah both
both were planned and it's funny though
she was just saying
yesterday which she might get mad my
wife's funny cuz she thinks I'm funny
but not everything I do is funny but
hope hopefully she don't get mad me
saying this but like uh two nights ago
we had we made love and you know she
hasn't she's still breastfeeding but the
doc said look man you're at the months
where like it could have even though you
haven't had your period menstrual cycle
you can get pregnant and so we've been
being careful about that but last night
I wasn't or the night before I wasn't
careful and she's like do you want to
have a third baby and I was like I don't
know I was like but don't stress about
it I was like I don't think my swimmers
are that strong you know right now so
who knows they're strong enough just 50
and you're having a baby basically and
you never know but I'm just saying like
I can't I tell her I'm like I wouldn't I
don't think I'd hate it again I love my
kids and it's such a beautiful thing but
it would be a lot but I'm like I'm try
we're trying not to have a third but
yeah she was like can you imagine having
a third it I know it sometimes I'm on
the plane man I'll see a husband and
wife come on with like four or five kids
and I'm just like how how do they you
know and they're all like you know three
five eight like they're all close um
anyway but yeah it's yeah people
actually loved each other and put some
thought and time behind
family so it is it's a great thing and
again I'm a little tired but it it is
again having a boy and a girl's it's
been awesome so um well the childhood
you're giving your kids is already way
different than yours so let's talk about
that you're from Jersey
you never knew your biological father
yeah no so I have I have a brother and
sister um from him as well no so we all
have different fathers okay and me and
my sister never met our well sorry all
three of us really never met our fathers
but my brother he's the oldest he's
eight years older than me my sister's
four years older than me but my brother
uh got to meet his dad once um yeah so
my mom was a dope fiend she sold drugs
she used drugs she wind up dying from
AIDS how old was she she was 53 53 yeah
so how old were you when that happened
oh I forgot it was we were just I was
just looking at something the other day
it was she would have been 70 something
so was like 20 years ago 20 something
years ago I was in my 25 I think matter
of fact I know it was right after J and
Bob Strikes Back which was 2001 okay um
cuz I remember we came back from
shooting the movie um and I took care of
her for a little bit and she passed away
and then I went like on a spot I was
sober so you did get yeah I did get to
come home take care of her for a little
bit and then she passed and then like I
went on a real Bender then and that sort
of when the first around the first time
I got soberish for like four years and
um so your mom has three children three
different men yes and the only one that
even gave a [__] for one second was your
oldest brother's Dad yeah um but did you
ever in your life have you ever met your
Bot do you even know
I don't and I the bummer is is like you
want to know I would I would well I
don't necessarily would want to know him
like spend time with him if but I'd love
to see a picture of him that's what we
my main thing is I'd love to see a
picture because I'm so curious plus he
has and again if my mom told me the
truth because again I would ask
questions every once in a while and I
wasn't with her um I mean it's a real so
like she would get high and then she
would get sober and I'd spend some time
with her then she'd relapse and I go
live with my grandma she then she get
better so on and so so when I was
younger I would start asking questions
and I remember she would a um tell me
like for a minute I thought his last
name was stanka but I don't think it was
because we researched and did all the
stuff I don't believe so but anyway she
had told me he um the reason they didn't
stay together is because he was married
and had three kids so I'm if she's
telling the truth I have three sisters
out there as well so he's cheating
supposedly cheating on his wife with
your mom finds out she's that's the case
then you've got five total siblings
three from this and then the brother and
the sister yeah that you share your mom
with yeah so that's that's another
reason I would it would be awesome to be
able to find him a just to find see if I
see what he looks like but it would also
be cool to find out if he really do well
sorry if I really have half sisters do
you have you done a 23 in me or anything
yeah we've I've done
23 no so I've done the TW 23 and mean I
haven't found anything found some
cousins but always from my mom in that
side but someone was telling me recently
that like you have to try there's
another one I guess it's a little bit
older um it's like the 23 of me it's
another company but my B my buddy my one
of my best friends growing up he said
he's the other day I we T call each
other every year on our birthday we''ve
known each other since we were five so
even though he lives in Texas I don't
see him we call each other every year
and he has a family and we you know you
lose touch but we call each other every
year and last year when he I called him
on his birthday he goes yeah I go what
are you doing for your birthday he goes
I'm going out with my sister I'm like
you have two brothers what do you mean
your sister he's like oh my God I must
not have told you I found a sister my
dad had when my dad and what mom got
divorced he had a one he was with
another woman and had a kid and it's a
girl and I have a sister so anyway and
then he was telling me this
he found her on this site um and he was
just saying it's a little it's something
like what's it I forgot ancestrial doc
oh yeah ancestry.com and he said that
one's a little bit more use because it
was around longer and he's and he told
me I should sign up for that because
more people use that and I have a
because I'm already on 23 and me maybe I
could find it but anyway yeah so it it
would be interesting you should also try
to figure it out just honest to God I
say this all the time to all these
people even if you don't ever want to
speak to him do you know if he's even
alive I don't you have no idea Health
genetics yeah cuz that [__] you're
passing on to your kids too and you know
what I mean like it's a lot of that [__]
like any kind of diseases he might have
had or any of that stuff if you can find
out it's just a leg up on heart disease
diabetes cancer any of it you know I
agree especially colon cancer testicular
cancer prostate all that [__] well it's
funny cuz I I remember when I start
growing long hair I was like man I hope
I don't lose my hair and that was one of
the reasons I'm like I wish I could see
a picture see if my dad still has his
hair you know but so what is it like
being you're you're a child with no dad
and your mom's a junkie and I'm sure
she's out there hustling to do what
she's got to do to get her fixed and to
oh yeah raise you so what's that like
like what are some of her hustles so I'm
it's so weird cuz I forget many things
growing up but one one thing I remember
I swear is at clear's day we lived uh in
in Highlands and I remember one one
night waking up in the middle of the
night coming out in the living room and
my mom had like three people in the
living room and there was all these tube
TVs around our living room and I'm like
well what's going on she said go back to
bed go back to bed and then I like of
course went in my room but I was
listening they went to hotels and signed
up in different names and it was way
back with the tube not even flat screens
that are
exactly so they would sign in in
different names and rip the TVs off the
wall to sell them for real even steal
the TVs from hotels and sell them yeah
it's
crazy and again CU it was a good and
it's still that that age where it was
like you know first it was like the big
box TVs on the floor like that look like
wooden cabinets so again there was still
like you get a nice TV tube TV with the
VHS V VCR inside you know you could
probably get a couple bucks so there was
that she also used to make me drive
around pull up to mailboxes you're Drive
are you old enough to drive no no I'm a
kid I'm probably 11 12 years old no my
mom's driving so my mom's driving she's
making me you're the lean in take
people's mail what do you what like
credit cards and [__] like that she's
fishing she was the big one that
birthday cars with cash in it tell me
11year old I didn't even think of that I
didn't think of that back then yeah yeah
there's no digital [__] email cards
or no yeah there was none of that
Apple what was your best day do you
remember a day you know I I know she she
would even get here's the horrible thing
she would even get people's like license
plates you know imagine you're waiting
for new license PL but we would go to
the duck pond there's a duck pond in our
neighborhood and we' go and she would
sit there and go through the mail and
just throw like you know plates in the
duck pond or like throw there's a big
garbage P she would burn the paper in
the mail but I feel like her for her was
credit cards some cash I remember one
time getting like 100 bucks she' get a
100 bucks from it and if it was in like
throw me a couple bucks I remember she
bought my one Christmas present it was a
Christmas present that I really wanted a
bike I didn't have a bicycle all my
buddies had bikes um I really wanted
this Sigma I remember Claire's there and
it had like the covered Wheels like the
that you couldn't see the spokes cuz
there was discs yeah and for Christmas
my mom got a credit card and like used
the credit card to buy me this bike and
the only reason why I know CU I remember
hearing my grandma talk to my aunt cuz
when I wasn't living with my mom I Liv
with my grandma for a while then my mom
got better and I lived with her and then
so on so so that and then another thing
that I'll never forget is my M used to
bring me and my sister to the grocery
store and she would steal cartons of
cigarettes from the carton thing that me
that's back before they locked them up
yeah yeah and so she would come out she
would like go in the back and have me
and my sister we on big um big fluffy
jackets and she'd be like stick this
meat down your pants take this Carton
and she make my sister put like carton
cigarettes you know in front of her
pants and stuff it weird [__] like that
but those are the three main hustles
that she like would involve us that I
remember um yeah it was you know and
again it's one of those things when I
was younger it's like we I hated doing
it but at the same time it was this
weird thing where it's
like I I you know it's like I didn't
want to disappoint my mom cuz I didn't
see her as much and wanted to spend time
with her I never wanted her to leave you
know um but that's all you have yeah I
mean really you have no dad that's it
and again and I love my grandma and she
took care of me a bunch but I really
didn't want my mom to leave so I'd do it
but the only time that ever annoyed me
was because I like but I want to go play
with my friends I'm supposed to go you
know to the park with so and so so and
one of the what happened eventually what
finally I had my mom like go away before
she came home and was sick um I was 12 I
remember riding my about to ride my bike
to my buddy's house she goes come here
she goes take this envelope it's a card
a gift card for my friend and I knew the
guy I don't want to say his name but I
it was my brother's friend so I knew him
she goes so and so want is down at the
park um give this to him and his and he
always money so just get the money he
owes me but this is a car how old are
you doing this 12 years old so you bike
riding down there whatever I'm going to
my buddies I want to go we're going
somewhere and stuff he's waiting on me
no no go do this so I'm like all right
so I ride my bike down give it to him he
gives me he's like oh this is my cousin
you know Johnny whatever this my cousin
Johnny I was like hey what's up man and
I was like here it is my mom says you
money and he gives me money so I ride
the bike back give her the money two
months later my brother picks me up up
from my buddy's my buddy's house again
um says we got to take a ride and we
take a ride and she says listen do you
remember going to the park uh the beach
and meeting so and so I was like yeah I
remember that she goes that envelope was
filled with Heroin and you sold drugs to
him and an undercover crop the cousin
Johnny was an undercover cop so you like
they want to press charges for you
selling drugs I was like no way I was
like I didn't know and stuff so I
remember they my mom like found out
disappeared we didn't hear from her for
about 6 months and then finally she
calls the check in they say we're like
my grandma's like look they're going to
charge him with this 12 years old if you
don't turn yourself back they really
were going to try they said they were
GNA they put it in the newspaper and
everything damn which was a real bum but
they can't put your name in there though
cuz you're a minor right no no yes but
but everyone's it's small town who hell
you along but the guy you initially gave
it to not the cousin was he also a cop
or was he working with the cop he was
working with to cops cuz he got busted
and he was even a really good friend of
my older brother oh really so like my
mom knew him I knew him um again another
thing I never mentioned was my brother
was never so me and my sister were sort
of dragged all over my grandma my aunt
my mom when she'd get better but my
brother's the oldest my mom was like 17
when she had him and she went to jail
right after she had him like a month
later so my aunt took him in and took
care of him from a month old to 6 months
old and then my mom got out she knew she
couldn't take care of him so my aunt
adopted him so my brother was always
around cuz he was with a family member
but he was raised by the same woman his
whole life um so your mom's been
addicted for a long time since her high
school days or before then if she's
already using at 7 she's getting
arrested at 17 yeah she was getting in
trouble so yeah and
um what's your relationship like with
her I mean when when do you ever get a a
time where you're like all right here's
2 years I got to live with her or was it
always six months spurts or three you
know what I mean you know did you ever
have any consistency with her well I did
only after she got excuse me after she
got out of jail that's a good question
you know when I was younger I don't I
don't know how long the stints were cuz
I was like a yeah you're a kid it's
blinks thought yeah I never think I
never thought of that like I'm trying it
definitely would maybe be but you don't
remember time like 10 grade to 12th
grade mom was clean and we were good
nothing like that it was always chaotic
yeah cuz I remember like third grade I
remember we we moved to this uh town and
and we were going to this different
school so I was with there for about a
year I would say at the most it was a
year and a half two years and then back
with grandma that's what I wanted to ask
you I was wondering if even though
you're moving around this area it's a
smaller area you're always maintaining
the same school with the same friends or
you having to meet new people a lot no a
same school for the most part except for
one year in third grade we did I went to
a different School uh in this town
called Kingsburg so I went there for one
year but for the most part it was all
Highlands so your only consistency
really was your educational system and
those people you went to school with
yeah yeah yeah my friends and my grandma
because again I I guess I was spent most
of my time with my grandma or my aunt
and then even at one point this family
that lived in in Highlands as well so um
but yeah so that was that was it growing
up then I moved out at 17 and then my M
got sick and got out of jail what was
she in jail for that time so so that was
for when she turned herself in when I
was 12 okay so she finally did it so she
came in sorry I never finished that so
she came back turned herself in um went
to jail for for selling and for what
five years so it wind up being no
because I I if it happened let's say she
I was 13 so about five I think it was
like six years okay so I think she got
six years for that damn um I think it
was supposed to prison yeah oh yeah
prison and do you go visit her while
she's in there you do it was horrible
yeah what's that like sorry it was
horrible because I used have to take a
bus for like an hour and a half they'd
pick me up at this what you had to do to
see your mom yeah it was like I think it
was once a month I think that I remember
but I know we'd have to go and wait in
this parking lot a bus would come I'd
ride like an hour and a half to see her
hour and 15 minutes or whatever it was
um and yeah and spend time with her the
only that is funny cuz I I had a picture
and I don't have it anymore but um I
remember one year I got to see her for
Christmas and it was literally a bunch
of women and like there's one woman
dressed as Santa Claus and like you see
little Jason Jason M like sitting in
between like this bunch of women and
women prisoners yeah yeah yeah oh my God
it was I wish you could find that
picture dude that's classic it's such
a it's so sad it would be awesome I know
I wish I had it I would love to post
that right guys we got the dates for
2023 locked maybe a couple more added La
Hoya I'll be back October 20th through
the 22nd Salt Lake City finally coming
back October 27th and the 28th hoping to
see yall out there but Tavia Illinois my
first time going there very excited
coming on November 10th and November
11th and San Francisco to close out the
year at cobs cannot wait to get back to
one of my favorite cities in the country
December 8th and 9th all tickets are
available on my website at
ryanr but the bummer is is out so in
2001 when my mom got sick and I lived
with her from you said she died of AIDS
yeah from Needles and stuff yeah from
sharing yeah um and she got sick quick
she got out of jail I again it's all
blur right now because I don't talk
about it that much honestly but when she
got out I went and moved it her she was
getting sick and then like at four years
me and my sister lived with her wife she
was like you know getting sicker and
sicker um and the Bummer is is then when
she passed my I winded up going the to
um Cal to California here because we
were supposed to do the JM Bob um press
junket um and I was a mess Kevin said
when he pulled up to the house to pick
me up to go to the airport so on J and
Bob if you notice I'm like a little
fluffier in the face and St because I
was drinking because when I first got
sober around that 99 I got sober for the
movie to shoot the movie Jam Bob um I
was like oh I can drink you know as long
as I'm not using drugs I can drink and
smoke weed weed and St but eventually I
wind up using but I got fluffier cuz I
was doing so much drinking I was all
booze weight all water weight I weighed
like 200 pounds um and then when my mom
so so Kevin dropped me off my house and
whatever it was like two months later so
my mom passes away like a month later
then I go on this Bender for like a
month or two months and I lose in like
two months like 40 pounds from smoking
crack doing oxies like heroin all this
stuff so Kevin picks me up to go to the
Press Drinker and he literally I come
outside and he's like yo can you tell
Jason I'm here to pick him up he didn't
even recognize me he wasn't even joking
no cuz he said I was like I was so bad
looking he thought I was just a friend
that was like a cracky friend like
coming out to say Jason will be coming
out in a minute that's how bad I looked
he said like he didn't even recognize me
till I got up to the car door and I'm
like what are you talking about man then
then he realized and he started crying
he started crying so then he we go to La
we go to California and we I try to do
the Press drunk it but I'm a mess
because I'm like sick at first then I
wind up getting drugs and um he's like
you got to go to rehab so I tell the
story because then I go to rehab for six
month or three months at this point and
I'm sending my well really Kevin's
sending my sister money to pay for the
storage she moves out and puts all my
stuff in storage my sister's a crack
head uh dope fiend as well she's using
with her boyfriend and she spends all
the money doesn't pay for my storage so
like I said so everything I had all my
pictures everything I owned like all
these pictures growing up things I got
from my mom is a bummer like got put in
storage got sold off like on you know
Storage Wars some out there got your
[__] they do they got your old sh they
got that picture of you
so let's rewind a little bit when and
why do you start using after watching
your mom go through all this you said
you were pretty you know militant about
not using it when do you flip and what
happened it's so weird yeah because it's
it's I was so I remember being so I
remember even probably 14 years old 15
years old one of my bud like a kid from
school is like yo man I got some coke
that St I was like no way man I'm never
doing that [__] so yes I was super
against it um I wouldn't even smoke I
cigarettes my sister used to smoke I was
like I hate cigarettes I hate drugs um
your father was an addict as well I
don't I know he was a biker well again
if my mom's telling the truth he was a
biker that could have just had an affair
and wasn't necessarily using yeah it
things cuz I again it was like I was at
the age where I was curious but never
was curious enough to be like hey no I
like want to know details like what's
his last name where's he from like what
I didn't even know what state he was
from or whatever someone at one point
they were like oh I think he lives in
Florida and the Bummer is even like no
one of my mom's friend we live in this
small town and my grandma didn't know my
aunt they never saw him they said my
grandma said she thinks she saw him once
and she wasn't even sure if it was him
when I was born and came home from the
hospital some man came out of the house
and then my mom said oh that that's
Jay's dad but she said she wasn't sure
of my M was just you know saying
whatever um so I didn't like drugs so 21
so I meet this girl such a weird story
sort of but I meet this girl um that so
my this kid I started hanging out with
uh was 17 putting roofs on house I'm a
roofer um and I'm hanging out with this
kid he roots with me excuse me and he
meets this girl they start dating and we
would go hang out but you know like when
I don't know when you're younger you
meet a you start hanging out with a kid
and like it's almost like when you first
start dating a girl like your friends
like why aren't you hanging out you know
like staying all the time with the girl
this kid I hung out with him every day I
mean I had other friends but me and him
did everything together we worked
together after work we'd go to do this
do that so he started hanging out with
this girl so I would always tag along
with them and then they're like hey
we're going to the arcade in Long Branch
we're going to go see my friend so we go
to the thing we're playing video games
it's awesome
and his girlfriend brings out this girl
and I'm not kidding she was like a 10
I'm like Blown Away how beautiful I feel
this girl is to me and I'm like oh my
God and we hang out the four of us and
for like a half hour at the arcade she's
on lunch break she worked there um and
I'm like this girl's amazing like I'm
like got a big crush on her so then my
buddy's like hey couple weeks later
we're going to go hang out and go this I
hang out with them again and you know
I'm trying to feel it out I'm like maybe
I can hook up with her point is I never
thought I had a shot with her couple
months later her and I start fooling
around then it come then I find out
maybe it wasn't months but I find out
they're using drugs I'm 21 21st
birthday and so sorry I found that
before they were using drugs I stopped
hanging out with them for about a month
I'm like I don't want to be around that
you're using heroin and all like we're
only snorted though you know it's an
only it's only a weekend thing I'm like
I don't care I don't want to be around
that and I was like you know why my to
my buddy and he's like I know I know and
so I didn't talk to them but I realized
like I sort of isolated myself from all
my other buddies my other buddy had a
girlfriend I didn't hang out with him
much my this so I'm like getting bored
and I see the dude at work all the time
anyway so he's like come on just come
out with us I wind up hanging out with
him again then sorry then I hook up with
the
girl um and then I they're using only on
the weekends they're telling me so we
start hanging out all four of us all the
time doing stuff going to movies doing
this every once in a while I see them
like nodding and doing stuff but I
wasn't sure yet MH cut to 21st
birthday I'm like yo man I'm 21 let's go
to a bar we're going to go do this I
could finally go into this place and we
can have fun and like man we're really
not you know we all working all day
we're going to go to um her house my
buddy's girlfriend's house to go watch a
movie just come watch a movie you know
the four of us I was like all right
we'll get a couple beers so I get like
we get like a 12-pack we go there and
then all a sudden they're like they go
in the bathroom they disappear and they
come out and they're all like and I'm
like dude this isn't fun like I like I'm
drinking like three beers they start
getting a little buzzed I'm like you
guys like I thought we were going to do
something have fun um long story short
um so then the girl they're like you
don't understand you don't know what
it's like I'm like I don't understand I
see you guys nodding out burn dropping
cigarettes on the ground burning the rug
and stuff like you don't know how it
feels you don't get it and more of just
like I'm going to prove it like I'm
you're full of crap I don't give a crap
I was like give me some I was like I'm
going to do a little bit I'll and then
after I hate it I'm going to tell you
that you're fools because what that
doesn't look fun to me um and then I did
it that's how it started yeah oh cuz a
girl but it's that powerful huh yeah and
then so I did it me and that girl laid
together dude and again I'm not I'm not
um glorifying it it's horrible but I'm
saying for that one moment like I did I
felt like I didn't care about anything
me and this girl we were we were like in
our own little bubble laying there
watching a movie cuddling and remember I
don't I was so focused on her and I got
sick even though I got sick I still love
that like because I was I felt great but
then it's this weird throw up where it's
not like when you're buzzing you're like
I'm GNA it's like you're like all a
sudden you're like hold on you know and
then you're like all right I'm good now
anyway um and but yeah it was great and
then I was like oh I was like all right
I understand I get where you're coming
from guys but I was like you know I
don't want to do it again but then of
course couple weekends later they're
going out I do it again and then next
weekend I do it again it's only the
weekends for months so I didn't have a
like I didn't physically get hooked on
it um but no time at all it became two
days Saturday and Sunday Friday Saturday
Sunday to you know every day all right
but I'm never heroin it's just heroin
yeah I don't remember at that point
maybe I tried a little Coke with it or
what have you um but I remember at one
point I was like all right but I'm never
going to use needles I'm only going to
snort it never ever and it was probably
a couple years before I did the needle
but that scared a [__] out of it is it
is but and I still didn't think I'd do
it but I remember when you're sick
you're so desperate you really are like
the
physical the physical feeling and mental
like you're it's it is like the worst I
feel I'm sure but anyway so I just
remember we only had enough money me and
this so now it's years later I'm with a
different
girl and me and this girl had like
literally 20 bucks we had enough for
each to have our own bag because it's
$10 for a it but I needed two just to
feel normal it wasn't even going to get
high I just walk around normal and I'm
like I'm not going to be normal like
we're going to do this it's going to be
a waste and my buddy's like yeah but
remember if you shoot it you it doesn't
goes through your body it dissol it goes
straight to the vein and you need a lot
less than what you do if you snort it
and I'm like no way I can't do it like
listen and then of course the girl that
that neighbor came over and she I didn't
know this but she used she's like I'm a
nurse she started using I'm a nurse I
look I have a Brand New Bag it never
opened clean with clean needles so that
it's in a sealed bag and then the
needles are in the little covered too
and everything's covered three times
over they're definitely safe and clean I
was like all right but I was like I
can't do it myself and she's like well
I'm a nurse I can do it and then she did
it and then you don't want to ever go
back the other way you know it's like a
whole another feeling whole another
thing and that was it man I just went
like it just I went on a ter yeah then I
just got worse and worse and I was
remember hiding it trying to hide it
from Kevin and everybody you know and
and uh yeah man it's was did I see a
story or something about he did he see
track marks on you or something like
that or something happened where he got
really upset yeah I mean yeah he stole
from him stole from him yeah I stole I
stole how' you do that so he I stole
money he had his wallet on the counter
and he had a couple like couple 20s and
I remember taking 20 bucks from him um
did he catch you no he didn't catch me
in the moment but he just knew he knew I
had taken it like he knew how much he
had I was sitting by his wallet later on
he didn't have that much money he
because he didn't have like hundreds he
had like 32s and I took one so then all
a su he's like I know I had $60 now 40
um and he's like because I told him
because I feel like what Happ I I feel
like he might have known before that
before I stole from
him see I don't know about because I
know his big thing is I told him I said
I'm not I as long I think because I was
talking about um how like I would never
steal like as long as as long as I never
steal and never uh do anything you know
Shady then I'm not that bad of a Dr drug
addict you know what I mean um but the
not I'm trying to remember when he first
realized I mean there was tons there's
been a few
situations uh with Kevin where when I
relapsed he found out one time because
he picked me up we went to um to go to
Vegas to go he had a meeting and he left
me and I was like I don't want to go out
to dinner but I had been clean for a
little bit and can I stand if I stand up
it'll mess up the thing huh so he he he
I'm like I don't want to go to dinner
and stuff but I stay I stayed in and
used and I got so messed up he said when
he came in and I don't remember this but
he said when he came in that I was
standing up in the middle of the the
hotel room living room going like
this sleeping standing up I see this all
the time that's crazy how you stay up
yeah but then he said all of a sudden I
got up to and I was
like
Shadow yeah and he said he was like Jay
Jay Jay what are you doing and he said
he threw a pillow at me and it startled
me but he's like he knew right then he's
like you're using again like um so that
was the and again so that was after I
read ups but yeah it's been it's been
crazy I mean the good thing is like he's
been you know again I really do feel
like I owe a big part
of me getting sober and staying on the
right track was because of him because
it's like he was always there like to
you know the first time we we went was
uh he threw me in rehab um I don't
remember where it was but and it might
have been it it might have
been it's so weird I can't remember
right now when the first time he
realized I was using because I but but
the first time it was definitely before
that time he walked out of the house and
he said hey can you tell Jason I'm here
to get him yeah no no no yeah cuz again
that I had gotten sober it was cuz the
the Dogma cuz it wasn't Dogma Chasing
Amy yeah cuz I start M rats I wasn't
using it was after M rats M rats is 95
so real quick I want to ask you this did
your mom ever get to see one of your
movies did my mom get to see one of my
movies yeah rat see saw m rats so she
got to see M rats she got to see clerks
um and I feel like Chasing Amy as well
um but yeah she she knew what I was
doing and stuff she she was she was
proud of me she was excited and and what
she was really excited about you know
one of the sweetest things someone did
one time is is when I didn't live out
there I still lived in New Jersey out
here I mean I lived in New Jersey when
IID come out to do things I wind up
meeting Paulie
Shore my mom's a huge fan of Paulie and
I tell him and he winds up calling her
and saying hello to her and it made her
day and then even after that when I was
like hey man thanks that was so nice and
sweet I get back home he winds up
calling me and goes give me your address
and he winds up sending my mom a bunch
of stuff like sign stuff had on the show
great oh it was so sweet like it was
again because at this point she's like
she's like really sick and like anything
you know it was so it just was really it
really made her day it was such a for me
it was such a like sweet thing for him
to take time and do that like you know
he didn't have to so but yeah so she got
to see some movies and stuff and um at
your lowest describe a day what is a day
like for you where are you living what
are you doing for hustle money like what
is at your lowest what is it like so so
I feel like one and one of our my lowest
points when I re when I went to get
sober the first time so it's a weird
thing I had four years sober and almost
five because again I've had months sober
here and there over the years from when
I started but I'm but I'll tell the
story so I I'm using I get I get better
and then I start using and relapsing and
I wind up meeting this girl and we start
using real bad and we're living she has
an apartment at this point she has an
apartment she's doing okay um she has a
job and stuff and I move out to
Huntington Beach and I'm living with her
in an apartment but we start using a
bunch um and she's using more and more
cuz she had used when I met her she was
and she even had the dealer um but she
didn't have the money and didn't really
have the drive to do it every day day um
she was doing it a lot like every
weekend almost um but her thing was
speed too she really liked speed more
than anything so then I started doing
speed which was crazy but anyway she
going from down to up yeah yeah so now
I'm doing like speed then we do dope to
come down and then all this stuff but
we're living there months go by we're
getting worse and worse I'm out of money
she's out of money and our lights get a
power gets shut off at the apartment
we're getting uh evicted all that stuff
and it's Christmas time so we you know
we're there in the dark at night time we
get up uh we this is so sad there we get
up enough money to get a little bit of
drugs we go down to our dealer and I
remember we're gonna like all right
we're gonna have enough dope drugs to
get feel better and maybe get a little
bit High maybe but we're going to feel
good for Christmas but all of a sudden I
remember the the dealer was like you
know what it's Christmas and he winds up
giving us like double what he what we
paid for he gives us double and he's
like merry Christmas and I remember
we're like oh my God this is the best
Christmas present ever we were so
excited which is so sad um and we get
home we're in the apartment we're us it
we're shooting up and stuff um and we
have no lights we have candles on the
edge of the
couch and the bathroom's upstairs and
I'm just too lazy to grab one of the
candles and try to hold it up the stairs
and put it some so like we would hang
out and like knot out and stuff on the
couch and then I would go in the kitchen
and pee in a bucket no I swear so I'm
peeing in the bucket also at this point
we're like just a mess so we like use a
syringe and throw it on the ground so
like the living room has like syringes
on the ground there's a bucket of pee
two candles burning me and her and all a
sudden we're like wake up my she winds
up waking me she goes get up get up and
I look and I can feel the heat on my
face and the couch is on fire holy [__]
the candle had burnt down to the bottom
and set the couch on fire and I'm like
oh why we haven't I mean is it just cuz
we're on drugs that we're putting
candles on the edge of the couch in the
first [__] place when you said that
and there was no like nice like we
didn't even SM enough to put it on like
a plate or
something we got to be able to see what
we're doing and stuff and I'm like
panicking I'm like I got to put it out
so I run over and grab the bucket of
piss and throw a bucket of P dude you
put a fire
[__] it's so nasty and I just
remember like after we like go outside
cuz it's smoking and we're like the fire
men are going to come the cops probably
were like panicking we're going to get
arrested you in an apartment complex
yeah we're an apartment complex onen
Beach and I'm like I don't know what to
do so we wind up just getting a bunch of
our stuff and we wind up getting out and
our Buddy says we can stay at his house
so and I my other buddy winds up coming
up I had this other friend who he was a
real good BT but he was trying to get
back home to to where he lived he was in
California to try to see his daughter
and get his his uh self you know he was
trying to he wasn't a drug addict but he
just was like living in in a different
state he went to Cali got a job was
trying to get an apartment and get his
life together so his wife would let his
sorry not wife but girlfriend would let
him see his daughter he was a mess too
though he kept losing jobs and stuff but
he had a car he was better off than me
um he had a little money saved and and
he goes look man I'm going to go back
home he's like if you want you can drive
with me and then I had a warrant out for
my arrest because that sorry one point
in 99 we I got pulled over driving home
from norc New Jersey to go home uh with
Heroin we get pulled over because we get
into an accident and we still go get
drugs come back home and right be like
literally five blocks from our house the
airbag went off but we pushed the airbag
back in so Kevin right ends up writing
that and Clerk's too there's a part
where the guys come up and they're like
yo man where you been and we're like yo
we just did six months in reab we got
pulled over for a deployed airbag like
Kevin winds up writing in his um because
Jay and and clerks too is sober Jay and
Bob are and so but anyway so we get
pulled over for real cuz the front car
is like halfway falling off the bag like
like blew up but like we pushed it back
in so it was hanging out and we're
driving in we get pulled over and I'm
like oh my God I should eat my drugs I
should eat my drugs I'm like not going
to search us but they wind up searching
us we get arrested and I get arrested
for a possession and they've released me
Ro and then I go to jail I mean I go to
court get probation but then I wind up
moving to California and so I have a
warrant out for skipping yeah for
probation uh or and skipping the state
leaving State and stuff um sorry so at
this point I wind up going to California
and I get off I'm even worse shape and
and that fire happens and my buddy's
like look I have to go back home and he
lives in uh Rhode Island and he's like I
will drive to Rhode Island and then from
there we'll see if we can get home so
you could turn yourself in because at
that point I was at so I feel like my
bot I'm like you said that I'm like I
need to turn myself in because either
they're going to put me in rehab or
they're going to put me in jail which I
didn't want but I was like what are you
facing what are the charges you're
facing right now a year a year one year
in in jail yeah for possession of yeah
hero yes but then for possession but
more for I guess that this was that a
hit and run as well no no cuz we
actually stopped and talk but um sorry
so the the year was so I had four years
four years for the drugs but then they
gave me a uh four years probation but
they were going to give me a year in
jail for for messing up my probation I
believe something like that yeah so I
knew that it was going to be about a
year if I go to jail or I'm hoping I'll
get put in rehab um and so we we wind up
my buddy winds up letting me jump in the
car and we drive to his to Rhode Island
um and things just got worse we stopped
in Tennessee um we meet some girls we
stay with them I me start shooting speed
with this whole crew and I'm like
hanging out this speed house which was
so crazy man it was such a weird thing
like windows are blacked out with Sprite
paint and people are DJing in separate
rooms cuz they're staying up all night
doing speed and people are cleaning in
the kitchen it was really weird it was
really weird um it was it was but
opposite of the yeah um but anyway so I
wind up turning myself in and I get six
months and uh rehab luckily I do six
months um and then I got out Kevin stuck
around the whole time he'd come visit me
he gave me at one point uh in three
after three months if you're doing good
you can get a job and he had uh our the
vew skew which was our comic book store
and then you know we had our merch J Bob
merch and stuff um and so he I had a job
at our store shipping stuff which really
wasn't I'd just go hang but I didn't
help out and stuff um but it gave me
something to do and and uh I got through
the six months and then I got had almost
four years at that point um but I got
kidney stones I stopped going to
meetings right so after about three
years I stopped going to meetings I'm
good I and I do I feel good I me I was
working out and I was all feeling good
and stuff and I'm like I don't need
meetings really um but then I I get
kidney stones and I have to they're like
look you're not going to pass the stone
unless we give you a shot of demoral and
some painkillers to because otherwise
you're tense and it won't pass and I'm
like I can't use painkillers I'm an
addict and stuff and they're like look
you have if you want it to pass you got
to get this shot and I was like all
right I'll be fine shot a demoral man I
got that feeling again like I got when I
was 21 with that girl I was like oh my
goodness and I'm like all right I'm fine
now you know I just got to take my
prescription as prescribed which lasted
about four days and then I'll sudden
them counting by four day four I'm like
take it was take one that one every 3 to
six hours right so I'm like it's almost
three hours it's almost three hours you
know by week two I'm like oh it's 2 and
a half hours it's only 30 minutes shy
I'm not really relapsing and then I took
my whole bottle and then but I had a
buddy who was like hey man how you doing
I'm like I'm good but I'm out of pain
medicine and uh my doctor won't give me
more and he's like oh I have a buddy who
has you know some extra um n uh well the
forget the name of them it's been that
long which is great it's not vikin it's
another one but perets not the perets
there's there's Oxy Cotton no not that
good cuz vikin has is
750 yeah so there was another one in
between and I don't know how I'm
blanking on it and it don't matter but
it was I think it was like 10
milligrams um of the the Codine that's
in it or whatever and only like 500 or
350 of the Tylenol so it just anyway I
think I have that a sopin I've got that
one it's it's hydrocodone with Tylenol
in it yes I got that but but the this is
suppos to be better and yes because if
you take like five vicin and you're
taking a whole lot of aetam metapan okay
these other ones they're the same really
but they're just a different name and I
can't believe I'm blanking on them but
anyway so I he he winds up giving me
some of them then I he winds up giving
me some and I think it's prescription
but he's like well you know he actually
sells them he can get more so I wind up
getting more more and next thing you
know it's a year later but a year later
I'm no lie just to feel normal because
in my head I'm like as long as I don't
do heroin I didn't really relapse and
I'm not that bad right as I was before
because I had almost four years um is I
was taking like 20 of these just to get
up this is what I hear from everybody
does the shows like your body really
builds a tolerance cuz I feel like 20
Advil for me I would throw up yeah but
over time yeah 20 there some people tell
me 30 I'm like a day yeah yeah one every
hour almost yeah well I would do 20 at
once in the morning no I swear by the
end I would take take five no I would
take five drink five drink I swear just
over the course of the day oh no no I
was taking like on a good day if I had
the money enough money and the guy had
enough I was taking probably about 50 50
a day I swear is that eaten through your
stomach alone yeah sometimes I would
taste it through my liver like it was
weird it was crazy but yeah it was a
mess [__] it was bad it was really bad
and and so that was that time and then
it got really bad and and then I winded
up going into uh then I detoxed again
and then I winded up and now so I forget
that little period I forget how long it
was so I think it was a couple weeks got
out um started doing the podcast Jam Bob
get old and three after I had three
months sober and then we started
counting you know podcast Kevin I was
like Kevin started letting me hang
around he was really disappointed me at
this point he's like I'm not gonna like
I'm not gonna like start hanging out and
doing things till like I could see that
you're going to like why do you think
you relapse and I explained to them I
felt like because I stopped going to
meetings I stopped being accountable to
people I stopped talking to people and
sharing what like you know but when I
got the painkillers of I was like man
I'm really liking this and I don't know
what to do I'm like scared but I didn't
I just started dating the wife I have
now um we had been together a couple
well at that point probably about a year
and a half two years and that's timing's
all messed up for me but anyway but I I
you know like I said we got a new
apartment me and her were out uh pad Del
re so all my friends were in there
Hollywood would so I didn't really no
one wanted to come visit every once in a
while so my point is it was me and her
every day just hanging out she would go
do her thing come home me and her so I
didn't really and I told him that I was
like I feel like I should have shared I
should have talked to her about it even
but I was scared to tell her um and I
didn't share with anyone like hey I
finished my prescription I'm loving the
way I feel I want more um or anything so
he's like well if we do a podcast I want
you to share like I want you to be a
account he's like if you share tell
everyone how you're feeling every day
tell some stories tell this then you
know you can be accountable yeah and it
was great because you know it got to a
point where I was like hey I have a year
sober and we'd have you know uh 800
people at a live show and and they'd be
like yeah and all I would I would
literally like we'd like we have a show
in tomorrow too and I'd go to sleep that
night like have a dream that I relapsed
and I'd have to get on stage and like
sorry everyone I have one day sober you
know and it frightened me though it
helped it like helped sharing with
everybody everything um and then being
accountable like after time if people
start listening to podcast online and
stuff I'd be in Starbucks and so like yo
I love the podcast how many days sober
you have you know that's great um and
right now uh speaking of that so today
September so wait it's July August
September to September right now yes so
September 2nd was 13 years and two
months congrats thank you thank you so
yeah it's it's been you know we stopped
the podcast a while ago but it was a big
help but really was um again the
podcasting you podcast is awesome and we
do it so you were saying I want to ask
you something sorry you were saying
earlier you do the show too do you do
just Standalone standup when you do your
live shows or do you do like a no I do
standup when I do live shows yeah you
come see me on tour it's stand up but I
started asking people because something
happened to me at the beginning of the
year where I went for surgery and then
they let me lay so long I clotted and
almost died and they were like look you
should make calls it's touch and go for
you so I started asking people if
anybody in the audience my first stop um
Fort Wayne Indiana has anybody in here
ever been given that you know
notification and right away some lady's
like I actually died and I was like you
died and came back and it's like yep and
then boom every city I've been to every
city I was just in [__] Tulsa there were
three people that died in Tulsa two of
them in Springfield there were two in
Tampa there was one here in Burbank like
it's wild
to know how many people been officially
declared dead called and then been
brought back and they every at least one
person in every weekend so far so it's
turned into a bit of a five minute
talking to the crowd if they got it but
it's just stand up yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy every city dude listen yeah
every city and I want to say like what a
hell of a story you have I've been a fan
for a long time bro he you're college
for me and everything else and I want to
thank you so much for for coming on here
thank you and sharing your story I'm
proud of you 13 years hell yeah I mean a
new dad you got a baby bro good luck to
your knees good luck to those knees and
you're back um last thing I want to ask
you I always ask everyone's first time
here especially after what we've talked
about um advice you would give to
16-year-old Jason oh
um you know I I would say I would
say because I always think at first I
would say don't do drugs but again I
feel like there is so much it's part of
what at this point so many things have
happened and stuff but honestly I would
say and it might be a not a great answer
but smoking smoking for me was so hard
to stop even more than drugs or anything
really smoking smok cigarettes was
harder than heroin because that's what
you always hear like it's harder than
heroin really and I I don't want to stay
harder in the harder in the sense
because believe me I want didn't say I
would feel the same way of how I would
feel if I was sick but I'm saying if I
quit heroin and quit cigarettes I'm
sorry the cigarettes were so hard
because I you can do it in public you
can do it so accessible
and the habit of it all like you know
what I'm saying like and I and again it
might be a c up but I feel like I
struggle with it because it's it's
caused fights with my wife and all that
again I haven't been smoking now for
months but it took so long even after my
when I had my daughter I was like I'm I
have a kid now not going to smoke and
you know I I didn't smoke for like a day
and a half and then I snuck a cigarette
and you know it just took so much and
again I don't know I just feel like it's
I feel like it's aged me a little bit
more than it would if normally my my
teeth like you know it it's it's
probably one of my biggest things I'm
sure there's another answer if I had
more time to think of if I someone sat
me down and say let's think about this
but I do feel like it's a big thing that
really sticks to me is the smok and and
over time how much how hard it is it's
for me how hard it was so well thank you
so much for coming on again one more
time promote the Cru everything please
Cruise uh is uh 2024 February 23rd to
the 26 we're going from Miami to Nassau
Bahamas uh it's the Jan Sal Bob uh Cruz
es skew uh we're going to have a bunch
of people on there doing podcast live
music uh some tournaments for poker and
some other things Jason Le will be there
Ethan me Kevin Smith um AJ Wilkerson uh
for standup comedy a bunch of stand-up
comedians uh a bunch of activities to do
come check that out
twitch.tv juse I stream every day
sometimes it's only an hour because I
got the kids sometimes it's three hours
I unbox things I play video games uh and
stuff like that but I also do my St up J
Muse and his amusing stories I don't
have any dates set right now but check
it out J Muse and is amusing stories uh
and I have my own website too J Muse and
all my socials J Muse J ay not Jason J
yme Wes is my Instagram and Twitter and
website and all that good stuff so check
it out well thank you brother and as
always Ryan sikler
docomo media come see me on tour get
your tickets at ryanr we'll talk to
y'all next
[Music]
week